May's trials were a complete success  it's too soon to say but they could be  the key to everything it's time now to  begin phase two  welcome to the Scorch the world outsides  hanging on by a very thin thread beyond  this door lies the beginning of your new  lives in Thomas weren't the only maze  do you remember about wicked I remember  they sent me to the maze I remember  watching my friends die in front of me  don't you want to understand understand  what why this all happened I just need  to know whose side are you on  they're hiding something one you don't  know that they lie to us we never  escaped it's all just been boiler plant  what do they want from amazes one thing  the two kids by the last one day out in  the scorch  what the hell  the course of your lives will determine  the course of humanity  into light or darkness  you